he was shot down in cold blood jihadi
John has been identified as mohammed
emwazi from west london we were not
doing you into Jamie's swing the new
moves between evolution am i tough
enough on top it off hell yes I'm
[ __ ] plane
knocked his colleague and
I've drove the air
the Raiders struck in the heart of
the general election is over and our
exit poll is preventing the
Conservatives are
his party
I said that if I didn't win I would
stand down as leader of UK I'm a man of
a word I must take responsibility I take
absolute and total responsibility and I
will now form a majority Conservative
government the full of carriage came out
of a loop and smashed into an empty one
that had been left on the tracks he had
attacked the tourists after swimming in
the sea with weapons concealed in a
parasol the vast majority the Syrian
regime
fleeing a warm
slaughtered by an American hunter
water Parma a dentist from America's
Midwest
golden electricals real
clean diesel was promised reality was
anything but
the man who became known jihadi John is
almost certain day
these people must love with
the eyes to the rights 397 the nose to
the left 223
he is now convicted of murder we should
not leave the acid in it